get off the fire rider
blood cutter
I'm feeling Ivory mate
[Music]
all right we've heard of things like
this before but I gotta admit I think
it's always funny
an American man who has no Irish
heritage whatsoever started to develop
an Irish sounding accent all of a sudden
because of his prostate cancer sounds
like Steve Green what green I've heard
people hit their head and that happens
yeah they speak Chinese and [__] yeah
they come out of accidents and they have
like crazy ass accents yeah but are
there accents ever like that accurate
though because I saw one like it was
accurate like some of them are really
accurate I saw one where this lady like
woke up one day or something and she
started speaking with a Chinese accent
yeah the British one right yeah and it
sounded so bad I heard you're the action
guy give me your best Irish uh I'm not a
uh accent that's what these guys said no
no I only have the German one the German
one's really bad German's very good
though yeah he just sounded not so like
this time is all you know I have to be
like like this like that yeah yeah he's
got it when he gets more intense
I don't like laid back yeah the Zohan
ones like that yeah I like to drive on
but sometimes I like to take the streets
as well like that is that uh Talladega
Nights he's a little flamboyant with
some German Shepherds and [__] he was
like French or some [__] wasn't he yeah
I don't know it's all the same right I
like the German fashion designer yeah
the German fashion designer style is
good yeah I like that so this man a
cancer patient in his 50s suddenly came
out sounding as if he was from Ireland
and continued to talk that way for the
rest of his life ends up with stage four
Irish was he also like where's me about
the gold
Strokes brain trauma hitting their head
stuff like that that makes sense to me
usually prostate cancer I'm like that's
interesting do we have audio clip of him
doing the accent we don't I think he's
just living out his dream to be honest
he's probably like man I'm about to die
anyways I always want to be Irish [__]
it I'ma blame it on the cancer I do
wonder if it's good he's probably a
really big Conor McGregor fan yeah
missed outfire or some [__] maybe she's
Scottish but it's awesome
yeah it is I've hit my family jewels you
know that's really weird to me that is
that is a weird do we have an example
uh go ahead Nick of an Irish yeah when I
think of Irish I can't help but to
channel like Conor McGregor you know
something like that yeah like what would
you say I bet bars got one 13 seconds he
would say something
yeah something like that one of my
clients he does a really good Conor
McGregor accent so every time and he
keeps referencing he always goes 13
seconds that's me fastest knockout in
the UFC yeah
and he says all the time and now that's
all I can think of the stuff that he
says is crazy though yeah Conor McGregor
it's like let me see let me pull up some
you know what it sounds like it kind of
sounds like pirate yeah Irish and pirate
kind of sounds similar Irish Pirates
dude
yeah what were the Pirates this
vernacular is just weird Pirates are
closer when I try to do pirates
sometimes it ends up going Jamaican
because all from the Caribbean
I don't know if that's true but
Jamaicans English I don't think every
pirates feel every pirates from the
Caribbean you don't know the story I
don't well okay so you guys know regular
Somalian pirates sure yeah those guys
like that's a pirate okay otherwise
there's a lot of boats that need [__] so
John is it Johnny Depp right he's the
main guy he's the main pirate yeah we
all know and love yeah he's a gay pirate
he's Jamaican absolutely yeah Jamaican
yeah see
illness
that's probably more like but I feel
like that's a [__] thing like it's
mean to say that but I'm sure a lot of
people come off of [__] just like just
off two problems I think it's here
because like what are the odds of that
like why wouldn't you just sound weird
why would you have to be Regional yeah
yeah that's true it's like why do you
have to sound Irish like you know the
lady that woke up with a Chinese accent
why did it end up being Chinese and not
just it was low-key kind of racist like
the way he used to do it I was like oh
this is not even a good Chinese accent
you know the very like oh excuse me
like did you hit your head [__] the
very first time I got super high right
just glad to be arrived
very first time I got super high which
was also just like uh the first time I
threw me off of weed and turned me off
because I got the spins and I was like
throwing up and all that stuff right
um there was one moment of it that was
[__] hilarious and for some reason I
could not stop speaking with like this
like Southern Texan like American white
accent you're good at that but that's
something that you previously could do
right but the thing is like there was
this uncontrollable feeling and then
even when people were cracking up at me
I was laughing so hard that I started
crying because you know what I mean
you're just so in it and it couldn't
stop so even if they were just kept on
poking at me about it and I'll just like
speak but not try in my head yeah yeah
in my head but it just stuck because
one of my favorite videos of all time
that the reels that you've done is when
Steve is doing like the the Sugar Land
oh making fun of Texas yeah and then he
he talks to you and you you go Barbara
you did this accident I was like it
makes me laugh so [__] hard because
your accent is low-key very good you're
Southern ax I don't know dude something
bad but that's what I'm saying maybe
home girl who woke up with the Chinese
accent you know maybe she can't control
the racism she's just stoned maybe went
in or off time she's like using the
accent all the time or maybe it's a call
she's joking around with it all the time
and it's locked in there and then
suddenly she can't stop you know like
what if we became the uncles
we wake up hey what the [__] man that
makes sense to me yeah you look like an
uncle I feel like some people watch you
guys speak normal English and they're
thrown off yeah they're probably
tripping isn't that a Tom Hanks son who
oh dude the [__] uh Jamaican dude uh
just you never heard that story no you
got you got a bunch of flag for it but
Tom Hanks on one be like a rapper and
all this stuff and then he did like a
Jamaican rap song you never heard that
no he got flamed for it no it's not
right but the Jamaicans kind of [__]
with them a couple people did because I
guess his cousin or somebody was like
dating a Jamaican and they were teaching
him the Patois yeah and so then he like
wrapped a song about it and talked a
whole summer about it and he got a lot
of heat it was a white boy summer it was
a white boy isn't my voice number but
there's white there's white boy reggae
and they're good and there's white
people in Jamaica yeah just not Tom
Hanks son right right because he didn't
grow up there right you know there's
like Japanese reggae artists that go to
Jamaica to study it that's it and then
there's videos of them just like singing
with folks and they sound like local
tools and I'm like it's the most honest
looking thing I love that accent
Japanese people don't count when it
comes to like studying other disciplines
and getting good at that's like looking
at Japanese cholos who drive low riders
with [__] flannels and stuff and
being like you guys are appropriate it's
like no they do it better than the
Mexicans I think as long as you're
paying respect to the
let's rock Japanese probably the most
respectful yeah probably you've seen the
movie Shottas no uh it's based on
there's a Nas movie in America what's
that called
but it's like a gangster movie and shots
is like the original and one of the
Marley Sons is in it and it's all
Jamaican like it's so hard that uh
there's uh subtitles yeah oh it's so
thick yeah because it's a whole it's a
language
can understand it yeah yeah it's all the
Pirates can do yeah the Pirates don't
need to read it they all are from the
Caribbean the movie's tough dude it's
one of my favorite movies Shottas
Shottas
you the thing that makes me think it's a
brain thing and not a motor thing is
that you think more people with speech
impediments would sound like other races
but they don't they just sound [__] up
yeah yeah yeah that's mean right doing
an accent is tough though too it's
almost like yeah it's like how would you
just cold know how to do this thing
that's kind of crazy to know the ins and
outs that's true because like the
physical part of it the equivalent would
be like let's say you sprained her ankle
and now you have you walk like a pimp
yeah rather than just walking like this
ability the Disney Channel uh movie a
kid breaks his arm Rookie of the Year
rookie of the year yeah now the dude
throws at 100 he just broke his is over
now he's a major league pitcher you
should just have a hurt arm like it
can't be better yeah that's true well
that's what makes it a movie guys yeah
but then these guys are living Rookie of
the Year just as a Chinese random person
but also too for those people I feel
like the longer you hear them speak the
more you're like this accent has holes
well also it's limited to the vocab they
know how to do that in I'm sure if you
ask them hard enough words it wouldn't
sound Chinese because they've never done
it yeah it's like come on man like
you're saying basic [__] they're just
quoting Jackie Chan all day all they're
doing is yeah
I'm cold I'm cold
they just keep replacing the R's and the
L's and that's the only thing they know
how to do that's ridiculous man it's
also conveniently like this is
conveniently a white person's
understanding of what Chinese sounds
like it's not it's not real it actually
sound like it's like that's how you
process that [__] yeah that's so true
though it's a 3.95
like that man yeah no one sounds like
that
I want to know which Chinese dude
started that [__] like in Hollywood
because no one [__] speaks with an
accent like Charlie Chan [__] She
Bangs William Hung dude he doesn't sound
like that though you sound like
something from the 1940s that guy
Charlie Chan
he played uh like he's in uh what is it
Breakfast at Tiffany's oh yeah I thought
that was a [__] Tommy what's his name
Tommy was up because he was the no
remember when that dude he played the
Japanese landlord
but you know what I have to say there
are Japanese people that look like that
so I can't [__] hate dude but they
don't talk like that though the accent's
all I bet if we look hard enough we can
find something
yeah with a circle glasses okay oh you
know what I recently said bro I don't
know if it's real but did you guys see
Drake doing Manny Pacquiao
and he was like singing in the studio
I don't think am I tripping or have you
seen the one of Snoop Dogg doing Psy oh
my God that's so funny
so I was like what's this guy doing yeah
he's like what all right so you're
talking about this right here Manny
Pacquiao sings
are you guys ready to go baby are you
sure this isn't Chris Sosa we are going
to start with this song from Frozen no
this is SNL times
people this is SNL huh yeah to buy it
all the time I can't fight for the rest
of my life Ryan what do you think so far
it's pretty good
footprint
the girl
literally that's SNL yeah
[Music]